hey reject nation Greg Alva here
hi I'm adorable rate time you did it
without me having to say anything
thanks adorable Rachel go check out our
channel reactions reviews you know one
of those we re watched the Aquaman
trailer just now so we can prep
ourselves for this video it comes from a
fantastic YouTube channel a channel that
deserves so many more subscribers dart
blender I think it's one guy who does
this something else I'll probably watch
over and over again yay so before we do
that I want to give a page from the day
shout out over at patreon we do
full-length TV show reactions weekly
humanities music video coverage may I
patron plug done but shout out I'm too
man named Joshua Lucero he's from Hawaii
by Aquaman impression oh thank you I'm
waiting for a compliment like that less
good-looking version I want to give a
shout out to Joshua Sun Jarek he's 8
years old
but he actually is a huge fan of this
channel Jarek I want to tell you you
guys were livin it up a Hawaii right now
going into the ocean doing all those
awesome things thank you for watching
this channel my friend I just want you
to know that your dad is a really
kind-hearted dude I hope you inherit
those same sincere qualities and when
you're older annihilate him
and take over the family throughout if
you're from Hawaii chicks love that in
California yeah so when you're a teen
moved to California you know it when
you're 15 move to California start
getting some 18 year old girls Oh kid
none s-sir and you're gonna do a great
job out here man you're gonna you're
gonna kill it with the ladies I can
really feel it Jarek Jarek the guy with
the bit up you're too young to make that
joke let's uh let's move on okay
my father was my housekeeper sound is
really good so far the highs ticket how
much what did you get I know
[Music]
everything matches it's great that's
great there you go
Wow great image gather right now
save my own people never well why do you
think you're on Nikita lead because
you're of two different worlds
you'll get a Michael Mann
I'm bringing the wrath of the seven seas
with me body shot
[Music]
you managed to find a moment where he's
jumping out of a plane great job again
you know what I love about this
especially when you watch the actual
trailer and then you watch this one
you're like man they really have changed
up the imagery to make Aquaman look a
lot more dark it's no orange or anything
they seem like a significant amount of
Clips actually seem in tune with what
the Aquaman trailer was providing for us
so it seems like they're still keeping
the essence of Aquaman alive in the
movie itself even though they've changed
up its aesthetic changed up its look to
make it more of like a brooding type of
badass character it seems like it's
still gonna honor it I didn't watch this
cartoon growing up I didn't watch any of
this I watched a lot of Super Friends
cartoons so I remember it vaguely first
of all I don't know how many hours to
find all the right clips for this is he
are you just working off memory I
remember this spot let me try to find
that moment or were you just watching a
bunch of going okay this one like what
is the way you structure this in
storyboard it's so you know how to
gather the right moments and how often
does he do these you did like a few in
the past month actually okay so yeah
this guy's a hard worker any time he
makes the video he's usually attack us
so we could do reactions to it this is a
glorious one because just looking at
what the retro Aquaman was when you
first heard they're adapting Aquaman
into live-action this is probably kind
of goofy imagery that comes to mind I
think a lot of us were like really
really pull that off you know I mean
they've surprised us a lot of ways the
DC Universe films in general have not
been winners but you never know I mean
Wonder Woman was great I like three out
of the five DC movies that have come out
so far honestly so we're gonna at this
this is this is all awesome stuff yeah
good job man I loved it I'm gonna
subscribe now it's funny that the
humanity even find an image if it goes
yeah how many hours did it take to find
an image of it go yeah
even being able to find a moment with
him jumping off of a plane the amount of
research that you put into this is just
so incredible man like it just amazes me
how you do this watching this back it
makes me go you know like the storyline
for the for the new for the live-action
one doesn't look too far off now from
the old ones but you should go back and
watch the old one guide no more at least
now they're like really creating the
world of Aquaman you know I was kind of
disappointed in Justice League that we
like saw snippets of this world and we
were like what is all that yeah but now
we're actually gonna finally see that
world of Aquaman
I'm excited dude hey Darth blender go
subscribe to this guy's channel you're
the bomb you guys can subscribe at the
reject nation click that notification
bell adorkable rachel follow her or her
youtube channel please do so or else
I'll never come back love you guys